- [Interviewer] All right, Spicy.
- Hi.
- [Interviewer] Spicy, where are you from?
Where'd you grow up?
- [Spicy] Chicago, Illinois.
- [Interviewer] And
you're still living there?
- [Spicy] Yes.
- [Interviewer] Tell me
about your childhood.
You had both of your
parents when you were a kid?
- [Spicy] Absolutely.
- [Interviewer] How was your childhood?
- [Spicy] I was raised in a very good home
with nine siblings and
I'm the youngest of nine.
My mom and my dad, they
were married for 57 years
when he met her she was
15 years old, he was 25.
And they were together up
until the day he passed away.
- [Interviewer] Wow, it
sounds like a good childhood.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] No abuse, nothing crazy?
- No (laughs).
- [Interviewer] So how
far did you go in school?
- I graduated from 12th grade.
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- Pardon me?
- [Interviewer] What kind of
kid were you in high school?
- Comical, (laughs), a
great sense of humor.
I was a great kid, everybody loved me,
(laughs) and still do today.
- [Interviewer] So how
did you get introduced
to the game because-
- Well, actually to be totally honest
me growing up as a child,
I can remember my mom will
always tell her daughters
if a man like you well
enough to sleep with you
he should like you well
enough to help you.
So I guess that's the intake
I got from behind that.
So that's what started me into the game.
And I also had, I can say two PS,
and I'm pretty sure
you're familiar with that.
- [Interviewer] Yep.
- And to be totally honest,
that didn't go well,
because you know sometimes
they lead you to believe things
that's not really happening.
And see I'm about me
and mine when I'm down,
and I'm loyal, you know, to the utmost.
So when I wasn't getting treated fairly
I left that and then I started to continue
to do what I was doing on my own.
- [Interviewer] And how did that go?
- It went well, it went well.
I had no one putting their hands on me.
I had no one just trying to degrade me
for doing something to help them.
You understand what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] I understand exactly.
- And you know, sometimes we as people
we look for love in the wrong places.
And during that time,
that's what I was doing.
But when I began to love
myself cold heartedly
I began to recognize my worth
and who I was as a woman first.
So yeah, that's how I
began to get in the game.
- [Interviewer] And
you're saving money now?
- Pardon me?
You're saving money?
- Yes.
Yeah.
Whereas when you were working with pimps
was that not the case?
- No, I was giving him every dime I made.
You know what I mean?
Because I mean, that's what I was taught.
You know, being in the game,
that's what I was taught
and that's how I thought it should go.
- [Interviewer] But what is the premise?
I mean, so what does
the girl get out of it?
Or what does a girl think
she's gonna get out of that?
- She thinks she's gonna get
the finer things in life.
You know, like homes and nice cars,
furs, jewelry, pretty
much I was sold a dream
and I brought it.
But when I became whole with myself
and began to find out who I was
and accept who I was cold heartedly,
I began to have self love first
because self-love is the best love.
You know what I mean?
People can tell you anything,
and you tend to believe it
because you're thirsty for that attention.
You thirsty for someone
to give you the love
that you needed, or that you desired.
But when you begin to
just separate yourself
from negative people, places
and things, you begin to grow.
And so I don't regret
anything I went through
because it was all a
learning lesson for me.
What didn't kill me,
just made me stronger.
And only the strong survive.
- [Interviewer] You've had a
bad experiences doing this.
You've been arrested, beaten up?
- Well actually, I've never been arrested.
I guess that was a way
of God keeping me shield
because he has something better for me.
You know what I mean?
So, no, I never been arrested.
But as far as beaten,
yes, I've been beaten.
I've been beaten to a point where
I had to have emergency surgery.
I'd had a surgery, I
can say this was about
maybe 10 to 12 years ago
where I had a cyst already.
And then I was beaten so
bad by this particular P
that I had to end up in a hospital.
I did eternal bleeding
the day of the surgery
which caused me to have another
surgery the following day.
So I had a back-to-back surgery
and I had to have a blood
transfusion behind that.
It took me almost six
months to walk again.
So look at me now, I'm grateful.
I made it through, you know what I mean?
Yeah, absolutely.
- Do you have kids?
I have two daughters.
I have a 37 year old,
and I have a 32 year old
and I'm not a grandma.
- Wow!
- [Interviewer] You don't look old enough
to have a 37 year old daughter.
- [Spicy] Yeah. I'm not a grandma.
I know, I get that a lot, you know?
- [Interviewer] And had drugs
ever been a part of your scene?
- [Spicy] No.
- [Interviewer] You stayed away from that?
- [Spicy] Yes.
- [Interviewer] And
doing this for a living,
I mean, do you ever get
depressed, or you know-
- [Spicy] No, because
actually I'm just gonna be
totally honest with you and
I'm gonna give it to you
in a raw because that's how I am.
I work a square job, now,
but this is my side hustle.
I'ma get it if I can, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I've met a few girls
that didn't wanna do interviews
but but they said, "Yeah,
I work as a nurse."
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] But you're
out here too (indistinct),
"I like doing it."
- Yeah. Yes.
You enjoy it?
- Well actually, to be totally honest,
sometimes I've had days where I didn't
even have to do anything
because I guess it's just my personality,
and my openness, and my being honest-
- [Interviewer] Guys like
hanging out with you?
- Yeah, they just like
hanging out with me, you know?
- [Interviewer] And
they'll pay you for that?
- Absolutely.
- [Interviewer] What have you learned
about human nature by doing this?
- Well, what did I learn
about human nature?
What I learned about human nature is
you have to focus on God Himself first
because a lot of people
set their alarm clocks
to wake up and things of that nature.
That's not the case.
He's waking you up, He's keeping me safe.
He's keeping me, He's been protecting me
throughout the game, you know?
And I'm just grateful
because it's some times where
I done dipped into guy's
pocket, as far as pick pocketing
and things like that, He kept me safe
'cause if they had caught
me, they could've killed me.
You know what I mean?
So I'm just grateful through it all.
- [Interviewer] How do you define success?
- Success is, I defined a success as,
it comes from the heart.
You know what I mean?
You can be the richest
person in the world.
You can have all the
jewels, all the material,
all the flashy things,
but if you're not happy with yourself
you can't be successful, because
success comes from within.
Loving yourself is first of all, you know
people feel as though
'cause they got this amount
of money that they're rich.
Ah hah, my riches comes from within
and my life experience has
taught me to be that way.
- [Interviewer] Do you find
this doing this kind of work
boosts your self esteem,
or does it also undermine
it at the same time?
- Well, to be totally honest,
I'm just gonna give it to
you from my perspective.
I wouldn't say that it
boosts my self esteem
because myself esteems
are very, very high,
and my life experience has
taught me to be that way.
So I don't need a
booster, honey, I'm there.
I mean, it's the fast
money to be totally honest.
It's the fast money, the
extra, the extras, you know.
That's what that is.
- [Interviewer] And do
you think a lot of the,
I think the majority of
the girls I've talked to
and the guys are addicted to the life.
- Oh no, I'm not addicted.
No, I'm not addicted because-
- [Interviewer] You can put it down?
- Of course, of course,
I don't wake up everyday saying,
"Oh, I gotta go do this."
As far as being a prostitute
and things of that nature.
I don't do that.
Yes. I put it down before.
But like I said, if it's
there and I can get it,
I'm gonna get it.
It's not like this is the
life that I live on the daily
waking up thinking about how
I'm going to get my next dollar
from the trick and things of that nature.
That's not my lifestyle anymore,
but yes if I can get it, I'ma get it.
- [Interviewer] You have
a very strong personality.
I'm sure that helps you
survive in doing this.
- Yes, absolutely.
- [Interviewer] This line of
work is not for every girl.
- Nah, they can't, a lot
of women can't stomach
what I've been through.
You know like I said, I owe it all to God
because I'm grateful, He allowed me
to see my way through that.
Sometimes, you know, when
you're in this lifestyle
the girls begin to play the
victim and things of that nature
because a person only do to
you what you allow them to do.
And those things were done
to me because I allow that,
but not anymore.
So I mean, I'm grateful today.
I'm loving me and it's all good.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think it, I mean,
it's a questionable lifestyle,
you know, you're doing
something that's illegal
in the United States at least.
And it's dangerous.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- [Interviewer] And then a lot of people
will be watching this going,
like, "You're crazy for doing this.
You're intelligent and
you have another career?
Why do we even do it?"
- Like I explained to you before (laughs)
and I'm gonna say this again,
- [Interviewer] Sorry.
- It's the fast money, you know.
The extras that's helping
me because I'm single,
you know what I'm saying?
And it gets hard for me sometime.
I don't have anybody saying,
"Here baby, take this
and put it on a bill,
here baby, do this with
this," I'm by myself.
You know what I'm saying?
So I have to do what I have
to do in order to survive
because to be totally
honest, my paycheck and stuff
it pays the bills and
this, that and the other,
but I mean, what girl doesn't want extra?
You know what I'm saying?
- [Interviewer] Do you
recall your very first time
doing this for money?
- Pardon me?
- [Interviewer] Do you
recall your very first time?
- Absolutely, absolutely (laughs) yeah,
I recall my first time doing this.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about it.
- And it's funny you said that,
because I was just talking
about this experience.
I can say I was about,
I will say 17 years old.
I was walking to the
store, I see this guy,
this flashy guy with all the jewelry.
You know those things excited
me then, but not today.
See the guy with the flashy jewelry,
and he was driving a
champagne color Excalibur
with the kit on the side.
And so I'm going, I'm
walking to the store,
and he's like slowly driving,
and he's blowin' his horn,
things of that nature.
So by me being in that neighborhood
the neighborhood was like
one big happy family.
And one of my mom's friends
was sitting on the porch
as this guy was blowing.
So I'm doing like this
'cause I don't want her to see me, right.
I'm like, "Come around the corner."
So he comes around the corner
and he meets me at the store,
and we talk and he offered me $500.
And I mean, me being the type
of person I was at that time,
I mean, 17 years old,
and a guy offers you $500
just to go with him for a hour or so.
Yeah, I did it, and
that's where it started,
from the walk to the store (laughs).
Yeah, that's where it started.
- [Interviewer] How do you
think all of these years
working the streets has changed you?
- I never really worked the street.
I always, define that,
what do you mean by that?
- [Interviewer] Well,
I mean, I didn't mean
working the streets literally.
I meant having sex for money.
- Well, to be totally
honest honey, me, myself,
I really didn't have sex for money.
And I'm just gonna be honest.
I will give a little blowjob
before I will let someone go inside of me
because I kind of always felt like
this is my temple and
everybody shouldn't be there.
You know what I'm saying?
So yes, I would easily give a blowjob,
covered that up with a
condom, go and knock them off.
Once they're knocked off they're dead,
so they're not gonna wanna go in you.
You know what I mean?
So that's how I saved myself
from sleeping with a lot of guys.
I'll give him some head and
go knock them out, baby.
Get away, that's what I do, get away.
- [Interviewer] Right.
So how has that,
doing this over all
these years changed you?
Because most girls don't do this.
- Pardon me?
- [Interviewer] Most girls don't do that.
- I know most girls don't do that
that's 'cause I'm not most girls.
- [Interviewer] You're not.
- I'm not, (laughs) I'm not most girls.
But like I said, it's a job to me.
I don't take it personal.
I don't let it get in the
way of me being who I am
as far as the relationship
I have with God,
I don't let that get in the way.
And then some people would say,
"She's talking about God and
this and that and other,"
but He knows that none of us are perfect.
So, and He knows my heart.
That's the most important thing
because Satan, he deals with your mind.
- [Interviewer] Has it
changed the way you view men?
- No, I can't allow that to
change the way I view men
because all men are not the same.
- [Interviewer] That's true.
- You know, I can't put
up this brick building
because I've been mistreated by men
and don't allow myself to be able to
receive that man that's for me,
you know, I can't do
that, I'm cheating myself.
- [Interviewer] You're a
very attractive female,
and you're single.
Do you think this
lifestyle gets in the way
of you meeting a guy-
- No honey, 'cause I'm
gonna tell you something.
I've met one and he understands me.
He have no ups and downs about what I do
'cause we're open like that
as far as our communication,
and I'm loving on this one right now.
I'm just keeping it 100.
I'm loving on this one right now.
He's an amazing guy.
I don't know if I should
say his name or not,
but, "Oh my God."
- You shouldn't.
Pardon me?
Right? I mean, he's like,
he's so understanding.
And I know he's like Team
Debra, you know what I'm saying?
Team Spicy, he's so for
me, because he understands
we don't have a problem about this
because this will be behind me soon.
I'm just waiting on him to just do
some more little right things to show me
that this is what you really want.
And then this will be behind me.
I'm not stuck, I'm not stuck here.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, what
advice would you give to a young
girl who's thinking of doing this?
- The advice I would
give to a young girl is,
she shouldn't, that's the advice.
And I would be able to give her advice
because I lived this life.
And if you're not strong,
it'll break you, it'll break you.
So I would say should she shouldn't, yeah.
- [Interviewer] What is the most important
lesson you've learned?
- The most important
lesson I've learned is
(laughs) not to believe what you hear.
You have to see it, put in an action,
because a person can make
their mouth say anything.
And that's the thing that
kind of like caught me
all these good talks, all this good game,
all these fairytales, you done told me.
And then none of it proceeds.
So I would say that taught me to just,
don't believe too much of what you hear.
You have to see it in action.
- All right, Spicy.
Yes.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- You're welcome, it's been a pleasure.
- Yes.
Yes.
- [Interviewer] Thank you so much.